Look, I'm not being funny,
but investing in space travel
is a total waste of money.
Really? I’d say it’s been a pretty good
investment.
Come on, it's overly expensive,
just a drain on our resources.
We’re talking billions being given up,
and what we get for what we’ve bought is
never certain, we’re just splurging all
this cash into the ether.
Sorry, I couldn’t hear you there over my
cordless vacuum cleaner.
Nice.
"Whurrr"
Very mature...
Well, come on, tt seems that you’ve forgotten
All the things we get from it.
Space travel gave us microchips,
memory foam, the internet.
It gave us cat scans, insulation,
shoe insoles, smoke detectors,
baby food, Boba Fett,
mobile phones and phone protectors.
It gave us LEDs, it gave us faster cars, better
engines...
Look, if you spent that much on anything
you’ll get at least a few inventions.
All I see is people out there singing David
Bowie anthems.
Don't you think we'd be better off
if we spent the cash on things that actually
happen,
you know, to people on this earth?
We do that too!
Really? It seems like nowhere near enough!
Whens the last time you heard of an catastrophe
occurring?
An earthquake hits, a tsunami strikes,
A hurricane emerges,
Or something worse than we’ve encountered,
whole nations ripped apart.
‘Sorry guys! There’s no supplies,
you’re going to have to starve,
we just sent our last trillion sending insects
up to mars!’
Fair enough, there’s costs,
But their relatively small,
and just because a mission sounds odd,
it doesn't mean it's not important.
I can't work out the use of hardly any of
their experiments.
Well let's start of with those disasters that
you mentioned:
Our advancements in meteorology have been
superb.
Thanks to space travel we can respond
to a disaster before it's even occurred.
And when we respond we can rely
On GPS and mapping while
We communicate, share facts online
All of which requires….
Satellites!
Which we got from...
'Space travel'...
And you really want to stop all that research?
That just seems absurd, I mean
Think of the lives it has changed,
the lives it has saved,
The return could not be greater!
Yeah, maybe, if you were born north of the
equator
You think that just a few inventions go
and make a great investment! No!
Not when so many people around the world
Aren’t healthy, warm or fed or clothed.
Space travel’s for the 1%, and those who
make the grade
as astronauts… well… they kind of look
the same.
The same background, the same gender
The same skin tone, we’re investing
In a programme for the future it doesn’t
seem all that progressive
Yes, we need more diversity,
This world is far from equal
But I don't think that's a problem with space.
I think that’s a problem with people
Down here, we try divide ourselves
through status and possessions
Up there, we’re insignificant,
We’re sawdust, we’re just embers
we’re tiny, yet united in this blanket that
seems endless
That doesn’t care about sexuality, class,
skin tone or gender
Our differences are meaningless
to the universe. It sees through us
it unites us, it reminds us
that all of us are equal and
the more that we explore it,
the more we all are faced with it,
it permeates our culture
our music, entertainment.
Don’t you think that’s a mindset
that we should be engaging with?
Let’s say that we didn’t.
We all made the decision
to just give up on these missions.
Great! Great!
Then might as well face
that we’re just living in a prison
Really?
Yep, that’s it, we’re trapped!
We’d be fine! We’d easily get by!
Yes, but we would be a prison of our own design.
We need something there to reach for,
that’s what separates us from every other
creature.
But we can do that here; we just need a sensible
perspective
I’m sure there’s rocks and plants that
still need testing.
Ok, fine. But you want to talk about investment?
99.999999% of stuff that we don’t know…
is up there,
in that direction.